and there's joey lucasie's numbers right
there a little deceptive his last three
starts he's only given up two earned
runs two runs total actually both earned
in uh 11 what's actually 12 and a third
innings tommy pham has had an excellent
series getting on base
swings to the 1-1 and sends it to deep
center field back is williams all the
way back and gone
home run to start this game a lead-off
home run for tommy pham puts the padres
on top one of nothing
where they needed that wow
talking about a way to start the game
right tommy fab continues his hot streak
with an absolute bomb the dead center
fastball up in the zone and you see
tommy pham get the barrel there well
over that center field wall to give the
padres an early one-nothing lead i just
think that it's a uniform and you should
stay
color coordinated i really do hosmer
hits one past the mountain should be two
lindora with a step and fire and hosmer
is grounded into another double play
and lucasie able to limit the damage to
just the fam home run let's come to bat
down one up on the hill is chris paddock
for the padres coming off a very good
start against the mets in his last
outing with six innings gave up the
three runs but
another step forward for chris paddock
and his usage of the curve ball has gone
up and he started to see a more
confident pitcher on the mount no two
pitch coming up here to alonso
and he elevates it 97 to strike him out
nicely done that was the elevated
fastball climbing the ladder and alonso
as the first strikeout for padding this
goes right along the lines of what we
talked about being able to command the
fastball confidence goes so far
in this game as a player
swinging a miss and that was great
back-to-back strikeouts for paddock of
alonso and smith it's one nothing san
diego so i think that that box needs to
be kind of moved a little bit to the
left
past the mound but right to the bag
where perez is standing four four three
double play and that gets lucasie
through the second two innings two
double plays behind joey
one nothing padres in the second
one audi in the second
and a swing and a miss neato strikes out
third k for paddock
two down here in the second inning
there's that change-up
and although we've talked about the
velocity of the fastball the location as
well as the curveball
really those things just open up
his changeup which is his go-to
secondary pitch which means the
strikeout totals might drop a little bit
next year
here's another strikeout for paddock and
for lucasie who has his first of the day
oh you'd be very sad gary a sad day
without pictures
most teams around the league have been
very cautious with their pitchers
padre is no different
on the ground and quickly off the mound
nicely is paddock and he throws out
guillorme we played three padres have a
one-nothing lead
some better cheers than this at that to
myers than what he threw to machado
seventh pitch of the attack coming from
lucasia to myers and he struck him out
with a high fastball
second strikeout for lucasy
up the ladder on him
remember lucasie has not gone more than
four and two thirds in any start hasn't
thrown more than 70 pitches in any start
so they keep close tabs on them jeremy
huffner has the pitch clicker in his
hand one two coming
got him looking
fastball on the inside third and kim is
out on strikes third strike after luke
casey keeps it a one-nothing game in the
fourth
well lindor started the rally in the
seventh with a lead-off walk in
yesterday's ball game wound up scoring
surprisingly lindbergh's got 26 walks on
the year so far it's kept his on base
percentage off that's drilled down the
right field line and that's going to go
into the corner for extra bases
and lindora pulls it at second base with
a lead off double
3-1 fastball
and lendore has his eighth double of the
year the man's second end of the day
there's an art to pitching up above the
zone there's a reason reevos is asking
for it in that spot
more likely to get a a swing from a
hitter
elevates and gets him to strike out yet
again and that one was pretty high as
well but
cannot lay off as pete alonso strikes
out for the second time that's k number
five for paddock today good old
chocolate moose right there
on the ground to short tatis from the
outfield with the long throw picked by
hosmer on the other side
so paddock does work his way around the
lead off double but he gets some help
from his friend
mets have been
very patient with
lukazi and i'm happy i'm very pleased
that they didn't lose faith in him 2-2
coming and rivas goes down swinging on a
high fastball and lucasy's got his
fourth strikeout 3-2 coming to mateo and
he struck him out
nice so he comes back from 3-0 to get
mateo
even today he's pitching on his ninth
day
and he strikes out panic and joey lucasi
strikes out the side of the fifth joey
goes five for the first time you can
always go back to being suited and
booted as he called his look
as a swing and a miss elevates the
fastball and neato strikes out for the
second time today six strikeouts for
padding
here's peraza
let's have their third hit against
paddock
and peraza drives one deep left center
field back
[Applause]
who does his best work against the
padres and the next lead two to one
well that happened fast mason williams
first pitch base hit
jose perazo first pitch two run homer
and just like that the mitz had the lead
against paddock who had been cruising
he hits a double play ball to lindor out
at second perazo with a turn for the
6-4-3 double play
the met's third in-field double play of
the day
1-2 coming to myers got him looking side
retired
bends but doesn't break and the mets
keep the lead thanks to the double play
ball
first and second one down and kevin
pillar all for two
swing and a miss as pallar strikes out
paddock needed that picks up his eighth
strikeout at a perfect time two down
season high and strikeouts for paddock
eighth pitch is coming up right here in
this plate appearance
neato takes strike three paddock
gets out of it with back-to-back
strikeouts nine and all
tying right now at third
go ahead run at second again the one-two
coming to grisham
struck him out
big strikeout for familia
now they're two men down and now the
base is loaded with two outs for tommy
pham 3-0 pitch to fam
that's ball four and the game is tied
from third comes hosmer and it's two to
two
that is the day for familia pitching
change from new york a brand new ball
game tied at two
chance here for the friars to pull ahead
in the seventh inning
a drive out to left field for tatis the
slam diego padres are on the road in new
york and fernando tatis jr has put him
on top six to two
with a grand slam
big time players do big things fernando
tatis jr
big stage big likes
big results the complexion of this one
has changed in a heartbeat
a drive to left field for machado and it
is gone
padres have gone back to back
fernando with the slam machado with a
solo shot and the friars lead it seven
to two
the floodgates have been open now second
time the padres have been back-to-back
home runs this season
oh
he gets hit in the helmet
did it get it didn't miss him i think it
missed him sounded like a helmet
it sounded like a helmet
he wants to go to first base
the home plate umpire last diaz wants
him to get checked first
he says he's okay apparently he says i
got hit in the c flap that's why that c
flap is there prevents you from getting
hit in the jaw
go to pitch
and that is strike three and the ball
game is over
now the padres take game three of the
series they win it seven to three